Las Vegas certainly has many options for
renters but sometimes when issues come
up in your home repairs aren't always
fixed right away Victoria Saha digging
into what renters rights are as a woman
shows us her apartment isn't livable
it's been more than two months since Don
Wood has stayed in her apartment this
was my toilet and this is where my
shower was but what's an apartment
without a bathroom it started with a
water leak in January one of the valves
popped off and the water started quickly
coming out her apartment is privately
owned when the leak started wood sent a
message to the property manager in
charge of her unit they ignore me and
they just kind of make me feel like I'm
a second class citizen she also followed
up with a formal letter in the meantime
water damage was building the HOA ever
complex had a Restoration company tear
apart her whole bathroom it's been like
this for months well I felt really
frustrated and and angry just because I
have every right to live in a place
that's habitable and it's got a
functioning bathroom when the property
management company silver Canyon Realty
did respond via text they wanted Woods's
renters insurance to step in tenants
Wright's attorney Ryan McConnell says
that's not right that's what renters
insurance is
personal stuff
homeowners insurance which all all the
landlords should have is what should
cover the physical damage to the
property we tried calling the property
managers their response to me is that
the damage is from the above unit and
that's why it's taking so long to fix
but there isn't a unit above wood the
delay to make repairs can have renters
taking matters into their own hands it's
really on the landlord to to fix these
issues if they don't the tenant can
either just stop paying rent or or move
out Victoria Saha 8 News Now